hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others
and uh let's see what interesting
questions there are today
ah there's one from Leo here should we
try to contact extraterrestrial beings
by broadcasting signals into space or is
it too dangerous to reveal our location
I don't know how much I've talked about
extraterrestrials and alien intelligence
and so on
um it's something I've I've thought
quite a bit about uh and I have to say
My Views have changed over time and have
uh kind of stabilized at a point that is
both interesting and not interesting
so
when it comes to alien intelligence
there's sort of a question
of what what do we mean by intelligence
how special is it
and how alien is alien intelligence so
first question is how special is
intelligence well you know I spent a lot
of my life studying computation systems
that operate according to definite rules
and perform operations
um and
when we ask sort of what's special about
an intelligent system versus a merely
computational system one of the things
that's been the result of a bunch of
discoveries I made over the last time or
40 years or so is that there doesn't
seem to be a bright line of distinction
between the intelligent and the merely
computational
when we look at something like our
brains our brains operate according to
definite physical chemical Etc laws and
the neurons are firing in this way in
that way according to those laws when we
look at some process in physics like I
don't know the the swirling air currents
in the atmosphere or we look at some
process purely defining a computer where
one just has some simple rule and one
just keeps running this rule over and
over again the question is how do those
processors compare in terms of sort of
the computations that they're able to do
and there's this thing I call the
principle of computational equivalence
that says that in the end the
computations that get done in those
different kinds of systems are actually
equivalent in their sophistication of
course we think the ones that we do in
our brains are much more exciting than
the ones that the weather does or the
ones that some uh computational system
on our computer might do
but in a sense the the reason for that
is that the the sort of an alignment of
the things that we understand the the
kind of narrative that we understand
about how the world works and the things
that are going on in our brains and it's
like you know a quote people often say
sort of as you know the weather has a
mind of its own well yes there is there
are computational processes going on in
the atmosphere that are quite as
complicated as ones that go on in our
minds or whatever else it's just that
those processes aren't align with the
things that we sort of are familiar with
as being sort of the thought processes
of um uh of of of of humans
so the way I like to think about this in
in terms of of sort of our latest
thinking is we have this thing we call
the ruli ad which is this kind of
entangled limit of all possible
computations and so all these different
things whether it's things happening in
our brains and the weather in some
simple computational system they're all
in a sense happening somewhere in the
rouliad
and they're all and in a sense
the question is can we sort of move in
the rouliad can we can we move from
where we are in the rouliad where the
the processes the computational
processes that we're familiar with with
our thoughts are in the rouliad to where
other kinds of computational processes
are and what kind of translation is
involved in going from one to the other
are we do we sort of uh that to what
extent can we understand the mind of the
weather for example well you know I
think we can sort of have some
assessment of distance in rule space so
for example between two human Minds
two human Minds will have different
representations of information different
ways of thinking about things but yet
you know with some approximation uh one
human mind can communicate with other
human Minds as I try to do in these live
streams
um and the main way we do it is we have
we use words we use these kinds of uh
sort of general concepts that are not
specific to the particular
representation of knowledge in my brain
or in your brain they're sort of
transportable versions of those lumps of
knowledge so to speak in in sort of my
life work of building our wealth and
language computational language the way
I see what I'm doing is to invent these
kind of concept lumps of computational
work that are kind of transferable
between in that particular case the
human human Minds human people using
Wolfram language and the computer
implementing World from language so in a
sense I view kind of the uh the the
content of Orphan language the the
structure of the language as being an
attempt to define something which allows
you to to to move from the place in
rural space that we are as human Minds
to the place in rural space that the
computers that Implement wealth and
language are
and and in general so you know between
different human Minds there's some
distance in real space people who have
sort of similar paradigmatic
understandings of the world maybe closer
in rural space than others maybe easier
to communicate with when we get to
things like you know pets and animals
and so on there's a certain amount of
communication we can do there's a
certain alignment of our way of thinking
about the world with the way that uh the
cat thinks about the world and we can
sort of understand the emotional states
of the cat to some extent by mapping
them onto our own experiences of
emotional states and we kind of
recognize that the wagging tail means
something and and so on and so on and so
on
well when we get further afield when we
get to the weather for example it's very
hard for us to align our kind of way of
thinking about things onto its way of
computing things or we could say
thinking about things so when it comes
to thinking about alien intelligence
extraterrestrial intelligence whatever
else it's it's sort of the same kind of
thing we can look at something happening
in the universe some Pulsar that's
that's rotating and generating radio
signals that are very elaborate and we
can ask the question uh is that is what
it's doing a bit like a mind well I
think we can argue that at a sort of uh
theoretical formal level it is a bit
like a mind it's doing computations just
like our mind does computations the
question is can we kind of get inside
what it's thinking can we align our kind
of narrative for how things work with
its way of thinking about things now one
thing to understand is science the whole
activity of Natural Science science is
in a sense an attempt to communicate
between the alien intelligence that is
operating in nature and our human
intelligence science is a way of taking
the things we see happening in nature
and trying to have a kind of narrative
description of the things that we see
happening in nature in such a way that
we humans can kind of understand in some
sense what's going on so you know when
we have our Pulsar it's doing its thing
maybe the Pulsar we might imagine at an
inner there's a sort of the question to
the Pulsar does the Pulsar seem like
it's got this whole civilization
Consciousness and everything else going
on from the outside we say that's a
pulsar it does complicated things we
might use science to make a kind of
conversion a translation between the
things that it's intrinsically doing and
the things that we humans understand in
our minds but you know one question we
might ask is does the Pulsar have an
inner sense of of what it is doing
you know we humans are convinced that we
have an inner sense of what we're doing
that's kind of what we that that's our
sort of notion of Consciousness is that
we have this inner sense I think that
the inner sense is a feature I think one
of the things that's very important in
that in a sense is that there is
coherence to what we do we have a threat
of experience we remember the past we
kind of have this thing where we believe
that we're thinking definite thoughts at
any given moment
that that appearance of coherence is not
a trivial thing the brain has has actual
sort of mechanisms to try and keep our
attention kind of focused in this one
line that is kind of our threat of
experience it's not obvious when we
think about the the physical structure
of us and our brains and how we fit into
physics and so on uh that there would be
this kind of coherent thread of
experience I think that the the fact is
that at every moment in time in our
modern Theory of physics we're made of
different atoms of space at every moment
in time the very structure of space the
structure of everything in space is
being recreated it's being destroyed and
recreated maybe 10 to the 100 times per
second maybe more
um it's uh it's continually being
destroyed and recreated just like in
this analogy I use quite a bit you know
a Vortex an Eddie and a fluid it's it's
made of molecules as the Eddie moves it
always keeps on getting made of
different molecules but yet we can say
look there's an Eddy and it's moving and
there's this thing that exists and
continues to exist
so
that's uh it's in that sense we are
these entities that like the Eddie is
continually made of different stuff
underneath yet we have this idea that
there's a coherent us that keeps on with
this sort of single thread of experience
keeps on existing and that's an
important feature of of having this
notion of an inner self so to speak is
this idea that there is this coherent
threat of experience and we can ask the
question you know does the Pulsar have
that from the outside we might be able
to tell them does might be able to tell
it doesn't it's not obvious that that's
a necessary feature of an
intelligence-like thing you know it
could be that humans most of us sort of
maintain a single threat of attention
you know there are things which people
might say you know that's a a terrible
psychiatric disaster If you're sort of
having multiple threads of experience
happening at the same time because
that's a very weird way to interact with
the world it's not some something where
there's necessarily good communication
between another person and somebody who
has multiple threads of experience
happening at a time but it's not obvious
that that the sort of the alien
intelligence that's out there would have
to be something which has a single
thread of experience now again so what
I'm basically saying is there's alien
intelligence everywhere the problem is
it's pretty alien and the idea that it
is communicatable with is is something
it's it's a that's the difficult idea
how far away are we in real space from
the Pulsar are we going to be able to
use science to bridge things so that we
can like understand what's going on in
the Pulsar or not
if we have that thing that we say oh
it's an alien intelligence that's a
process going on on this planet here are
we going to be able to bridge to
understand so that we humans can
understand yes we get it those those uh
those those things that that might we
might think of as rocks or something
they're actually part of a civilization
and those are the the great built
structures of the civilization they're
the you know they're the the cities of
that Civilization are these collections
of what might to us naively seem like
rocks
so
this question then of of uh okay so the
question was asked here was should we
reveal our location to the aliens
okay interesting question so what do we
do so let's say we beam radio signals
out into the cosmos
we might say well okay fine but could be
the case that that electromagnetic
radiation going out into the cosmos has
some effect somewhere probably won't
have much effect but let's say it does
have some effect let's say that
radiation uh you know let's say a little
bit of that radiation was beamed in the
direction of I don't know the star
Betelgeuse Big Red Giant star it's some
which at some point in the next million
years will probably go supernova and and
somehow that radio signal and I don't
really know how this would work but
somehow that radio signal Just Hits that
start just the right way so that it
initiates some uh you know some flow of
of Magneto magnetic gas or something
which somehow leads to the star
imploding and going Supernova and
there's a big bang and I don't think it
would do anything to this like 200 light
years from Earth I don't think it will
do anything too terrible to the Earth
um oh that might be a little exotic what
happens with the sky being bright at
night and things like this but for a few
days but um
but that's a case where you could say
well we we revealed our location you
know the the maybe that beam of
electromagnetic energy caused this
magnetohydrodynamic process to be
pointing in our Direction maybe it
released more energy in our Direction I
don't know it's a physics story what I
think one imagines is the more science
fiction movie story of there was a
signal and uh we sent out that radio
signal and then somebody came in a
spacecraft and came and and stomped on
us
um but I think it's worth realizing that
that story it's sort of a continuous
gradation from that story where you say
it's a human-like thing that has
intentions and has and is making Empires
and things like that two it is a purely
physical process which by virtue of this
you know electromagnetic pulse that's
going out from the Earth causes this to
happen and that to happen which causes
some effect back on the Earth
frankly I think these effects are fairly
tenuous and I think in mostly the
universe different parts of the universe
kind of keep to themselves mostly the
effect of something happening far away
in the universe right now doesn't seem
to be that great to us you know we see
Starlight okay that's fine it's pretty
small effect we see gravitational
radiation we can see the merger of black
holes we can see it almost all the way
across the universe we can see that but
it's a it's a tiny effect it doesn't
have an effect on our sort of everyday
life
now you know having said that I suppose
you know what effect do the stars have
on our everyday life this is a thing you
know back in Babylonian times when
astronomy and astrology were really one
field there was kind of this idea that
uh that originated at that time that you
know the configuration of stars has a
direct effect on our everyday life uh
most of the time one doesn't believe
that that's the case right now
um one one thinks you know the Stars
even the planets uh don't have a direct
effect on the things that we do in our
everyday life now of course that would
change if uh if our technology was
different you know if we were routinely
using the position of the planet Jupiter
or something as a uh for example people
at one time were thinking of using the
moons of Jupiter as a navigation
technique and then it would start
mattering to us where is Jupiter is it
above the Horizon is it not can I tell
the time by looking at the the the
configuration of the moons of Jupiter
then you'd start to Really Care in a
sort of everyday way about where Jupiter
is which we don't right now care about
uh it doesn't it's it's some now you
know having said that
you can certainly imagine you know the
the ancient um uh you know in in times
when there wasn't um artificial light
and so on and uh it was really pretty
dark at night and what was there to look
at well there were the stars and people
would no doubt have um have put much
more emphasis on on the configuration of
stars and so on and uh you know this
question of do the does the
configuration of stars have an effect on
life on Earth uh well I don't know and
you know when for example a comet would
come through and you would see this kind
of um uh wandering star come in as well
I guess planets were that were called
that too but when you would see this
sort of unusual Comet arrive that you
just didn't hadn't seen before people
might have all kinds of conclusions
about what that would mean for sort of
uh for for for sort of everyday human
life but mostly mostly the universe the
different parts of the universe have
capture themselves so I suppose the
question is if we we do something to
specifically communicate that we're here
and uh that where we're not sort of
keeping to ourselves as much as we might
now there are plenty of astrophysical
phenomena you know Jets or particles
that that send huge amounts of radio
energy in a particular direction uh
giant gamma-ray bursts that that go in a
somewhat targeted way and so on there
are plenty of phenomena astrophysically
even in other galaxies and so on that uh
you know deliver sort of signals in a
particular direction but I I think um uh
you know mostly that hasn't had a big
effect on the universe so really the
issue is is there some alien
intelligence
that might be close enough in rural
space to us that we'd say yeah yeah
they're really coming to conquer us
they're making an empire as opposed to
just it's a cloud of gas and it extended
across this or it's an Interstellar
meteorite that that um uh you know came
from here to there you know the
interstellar meteorite might have had
some whole life story that um we could
start to tell in in something that
sounds narrative and human-like but
actually we might also say it's just a
rock that happened to get thrown out of
some some some
exoplanet solar system and arrived here
so
I think um uh I think the philosophy of
the question of sort of alien
intelligence and the effect of revealing
our location it's a philosophically
complicated issue and I think it's one
that um uh I I'm I'm not really worried
about the human-like Empire Builders
showing up and deciding to colonize the
Earth that seems to me to be a a um uh a
tenuous
um kind of concern I think there are
things we might uh so at least pause for
a moment to think about like there are
things that we can create with
technology that have never been created
since the beginning of the universe so
far as we know not sure that's really
right actually I think that when people
have said that particle accelerators can
create energy densities that are as
intense as happened at the beginning of
the universe and haven't been created
since I bet that isn't true I bet there
are situations around black holes in
various situations of of high energy
galaxies and things where yes you can
absolutely create those kinds of
energies in fact I I'm pretty sure
that's true because among other things
cosmic rays which are always bombarding
the atmosphere of the earth mostly
protons mostly they come from the Sun
but some of them come from much much
further away some of them come even from
outside our galaxy and the energies of
some of those cosmic rays are incredibly
high like the energy is such that if if
one of those cosmic ray protons were to
you know were to hit me now mostly it
would just go through me and It produced
a bunch of particles and and then they
would but if that Proton really stopped
inside me it would give me a big kick
and that's quite a remarkable thing for
a single proton to be able to do the
highest energies that have been observed
are around 100 joules or so
um which is uh just a you know a
substantial amount of of sort of
mechanical energy so to speak now again
in actuality when one of those particles
which are very rare and cosmic rays uh
goes through something it doesn't all
stop in the thing so it doesn't transfer
all its momentum to the thing that it
initially interacts with instead it
produces a Cascade of other particles
and they get absorbed and further away
and eventually that momentum is
transferred but it doesn't doesn't
immediately get so
but I think that um uh there are uh I
guess I was I was saying that there are
there are sort of um
uh this question of whether there are
things we might be doing now that really
haven't happened since the beginning of
the universe I I sort of doubt it given
given the presence of things like very
high energy cosmic rays and so on
all right another question here
ah there's a question here about from
Satan how to tell if something is
natural or artificial yeah yeah an
interesting question
uh it's a question that shows up in all
kinds of places it shows up in
archeology
you know was this arrangement of stones
natural or artificial
it shows up in uh something like um oh I
don't know when people are like scanning
the ocean for a shipwreck you know you
got lots of rocks and other things in
the ocean what's the signature of
something that was a human-made uh thing
another example would be uh sort of
captures on um you know is this a bot or
is it an actual human behind it is it is
it a
um is it an artificial thing or that's
not really quite natural that's sort of
a simple rule-based thing that is is a
bot
um is you know I'm not sure that um you
know when you run a neural net and it
produces some picture where it produces
some chunk of text do we think of that
as natural or do we think of that as
artificial if artificial means there was
a human intent somewhere in the middle
of it that's that's perhaps our
operational definition and that's what
one tries to figure out you know a
website might try to figure out what the
capture was there really a human in the
loop here or was there something purely
automatic
um
you know I think this problem of how do
you know if something is natural or
artificial
a lot of the ways that one recognizes
things as artificial have to do with
simplicity
so for example when you see on the earth
a perfect straight line you think oh
that must be made by something uh that
must be an artificial thing that must be
a train line that must be a a Causeway
that must be something sort of
artificially made on the other hand when
you see something complicated you might
say oh that that must be a natural thing
it's a little bit screwy because we
think of ourselves as you know we're the
great intelligent things on this planet
and yet the things that are most visibly
artificial are the things that are
actually have simple geometries and
things like that most of our technology
also we kind of recognize this is a
technological thing but and we recognize
it by virtue of kind of the the the
Simplicity of the structures in it
straight lines circles levers cogs
things like this and part of that
recognition is historical that as we say
I've seen a cog before maybe somebody
could have been invented some kind of
thing that's just some smooth surface
that rubs against another one and so on
it doesn't look like a cog and we
wouldn't be able to say oh my gosh this
thing is full of cogs
um so it's partly the the detailed
history of human technology that's led
us to have these sort of recognizable
features but it is something where in a
sense it's a bit of an embarrassment
that the things that look
uh artificial are the things that are
somehow simpler than the things we see
in nature you know one of the examples I
find fun is um uh it's it's actually a
quote from Emmanuel Kant philosopher in
the 1700s
um who was uh uh said you know
if you see a hexagon drawn on the ground
you know that it must have been
intentionally created okay well turns
out people have now find found sort of
cases where the pattern of flow of of of
winds and convection cells and so on
causes some sand to be arranged in
hexagonal patterns you see that in rocks
you see kind of Devil's Causeway type
rocks where there are a nice hexagonal
kinds of rocks these are things which
indeed they were not you know can't was
wrong they were not things that had a
human-like intent to them they were just
things that happened as some
um uh as As a matter of sort of natural
processes I think an extreme example of
that is the North Pole I think it is of
Saturn has a giant storm visible through
telescopes that's in a hexagonal shape
so these things where you think this is
you know oh we're going to have a
hexagon it's going to be a um a thing
that we can recognize as being uh sort
of human intentionally made uh that
doesn't really make the cut you know
it's a it's a kind of a fun thought
experiment let's say in a future uh
moment in Civilization we get to be sort
of uh effective enough at doing things
that we can move Stars around in some
pattern what pattern would we put them
in so that sort of the alien
intelligences would recognize them as
being a sign of an intelligence like us
I don't know I mean clearly if you say
if you put sort of standard writing in
something then anybody who sees it who
is part of sort of our cultural thread
will say oh yeah I recognize that that's
piece of English writing or even I
recognize that that's writing now you
know there may very well be things that
are in in cave paintings or or things
you know carved out of stone or whatever
which actually to somebody at the time
not that they would have used those
words to describe it they would say
that's my writing
um and uh but to us today uh it's like
that's just a bunch of scratches I don't
know what that is good example sort of
intermediate thing is the kippus kapoos
and that you find in Peru these kind of
things made of lots of strings with
knots on them I don't think anybody
knows what those actually mean clearly
they were done on purpose maybe they
were an accounting system maybe they
were just a generic way to record
information they were clearly somebody
actually made those knots
but what do they mean uh and do they
mean anything I mean could it be the
case that the people just made those
knots decoratively ornamentally just
because oh I don't just want straight
strings I want strings that have knots
in them because they look nicer you know
we don't really know that thread of
History has been broken so we don't sort
of have that cultural connection that
allows us to know that
so uh
that's um
some thoughts on that
oh my uh
it's a question from Ark here how far
can an EMP from the human heart travel
so
I think well electric EMP will be
electromagnetic pulse usually you use
that term to talk about huge
electromagnetic pulses made by nuclear
explosions in orbit and things like this
but one can when there is the heart is
an electrically driven thing there are
nerves that come from one's brain that
um uh are very well protected knows
someone's neck that um uh are pulsing
electrical signals to the heart to get
it to beat
um and you know once it has that pulse
the heart is arranged so that if it's
working correctly so to speak it just
goes jump and and pumps blood and does
all the right things uh what when when
the heart isn't working quite right or
worst case when it fibrillates and um uh
that means that it's it gets the signal
perhaps to um uh to beat but it doesn't
it doesn't it doesn't operate in the way
that it's supposed to operate and it
doesn't just have its sort of smooth
beating motion and starts sort of
flopping all over the place and not
successfully pushing blood around
but you know the way hearts are set up
um they have uh that their their
structure is such that you just poke
them and they tend to just go and do
this pretty elaborate beating motion
it's it's a phenomenon
um
so-called attractor so so the very
simplest kinds of attractors you can
think of in a mechanical system it's
just like you've got this whole
landscape and you roll a ball and it
rolls down to the lowest point and that
lowest point is kind of an attractor on
the landscape all these balls roll to
that point so maybe you have a watershed
where you know on one side of the
mountain range the water is all flowing
down to one side the other side of the
mountain range is all flowing down to
the other side that might be two
different attractors
the heart is a more complicated kind of
attractor that's a limit cycle attractor
that is something where when uh what
from lots of different kinds of ways it
might get sort of stimulated it ends up
going into the state where it where it
is always uh having this repetitive
motion I think the same kind of thing
happens a little bit it's a slightly
different but a little bit like with a
swing uh you know you can you know you
you sort of pump the swing you're doing
all kinds of all kinds of different ways
but in the end it's going to swing back
and forth at a certain frequency and
that's the uh that's sort of the thing
that you're going to get to
okay so anyway Hearts have this
electrical pulse they um uh they uh they
also have
um they they have lots of electrical
activity associated with the the the the
well the the actually I'm now well okay
so so
um there's electrical activity that uh
is what you detect when you do an EKG
and when you do an EKG you put
electrodes on different places on your
on your body and the electrical signals
are going from your heart from the
junction between nerves and muscles in
the heart and they're going and you're
detecting those and you're detecting
them at
um uh by having different locations on
your body you're able to detect
different parts of the cycle that
corresponds to Heartbeats And so you'll
have um I don't know this stuff too well
but but you'd have um uh what is it the
QRS interval all there are different
parts of a heartbeat that show up as
different pieces of the pulses that
correspond to EKG
electroencephalography and an
electrocardiography
um electroencephalography is for brain
waves
um and I think I think the case because
it was originally in German if I
remember correctly and strangely there's
a you know the whole development of EKG
happened in the early 1900s it was a
pretty early application of kind of
radio-ish type things and also of
amplifiers the ability to amplify small
electrical signals
um and there's sort of a a um uh there's
a lot of kind of both folklore and what
later became science was also a place
where where sort of AI in medicine came
very early I I think it must have been
maybe the 1970s certainly by the 1980s
there was automatic interpretive EKG
where you would have some uh
you'd have an EKG signal and just a
bunch of Wiggles but
um it could tell you you know that's a
normal Rhythm or that's abnormal that
corresponds to some kind of arrhythmia
that corresponds to this or that it was
a very early place where kind of AI came
into medicine and became a very standard
thing
um as as a as a thing that could
automatically be done okay but the
question here is when you have these
electrical signals normally you have
electrodes you stick them on they have
you know sticky stuff on them and
there's a little piece of metal in the
electrode and you're actually touching
the electrode against your skin and you
are a conductor of electricity you're
you um you have enough
um uh you have um uh you know a human a
human body is a it's not a great
conductor of electricity it's not like a
copper wire or something but we're an
okay conductor of electricity which is
kind of a good it's it's it has various
good effects but it also has some the
effect I mean I I should explain nerves
uh are uh sort of efficient conductors
of electricity but also just general
tissue is also a conductor of
electricity in the same way that
seawater is a conductor of electricity
and for the same kinds of reasons it's
this kind of ionic salty thing that
we're we're kind of made of that
conducts electricity so when we can
connect an electrode from an EKG device
to us where we physically have a metal
electrode that then goes to you know
sends the electricity in a wire and
we're we're physically connecting to our
skin and we're then that's sort of
connected to the bag of salt water that
is us and we're able to to find
electrical signals that way now
is uh so if we say out from us if we're
like away from us how do we detect uh
can we detect the electrical signal from
from a heart for example uh my guess is
that that
um
in with a sufficiently sensitive
detector yes and one of the features of
sensors is they always get better that's
been a progression you know that has
been going on for
a hundred and at least 140 years or so
since the early invention of amplifiers
and so on we've been progressively
getting more and more and more sensitive
sensors there's kind of a whole concept
nowadays of quantum sensors
where you're trying to sense the the
effect on single electrons single atoms
things like that
um in as a way to detect very
sensitively for example magnetic fields
so I don't know if the heart produces
significant magnetic fields it must
produce some because whenever there's
sort of moving electrical uh uh charges
you get magnetic fields for example in
the brain where we've got all these
neurons that are firing and having
little electrical pulses they're also
magnetic pulses there and there is a
mechanism for doing magnetic Meg
magnetic encephalography which was so
popular 25 years ago I don't haven't
heard about it much recently
um where you are able to detect a
magnetic sort of emanations from the
brain my guess is the same thing could
be done for the heart although I have
never heard of it being done
um and uh you know one can expect that
sort of eventually from a distance you
should be able to detect those things
now the problem with Meg for example is
I know back 25 years ago or so now
people had a lot of trouble because you
had to be in this incredibly
electrically quiet environment where
there are no you know uh buzzing
fluorescent light bulbs there are no
um uh you know there's no Mains
electricity with with all kinds of all
kinds of electromagnetic signals there
you have to be in this very
electromagnetically quiet environment to
be able to detect these incredibly small
signals and so that's a that's a
challenge but I have to say that those
kinds of challenges again when there's a
background noise to a signal again the
the world of signal processing
Communications has shown over and over
again that by cleverness engineering
cleverness you get to sort of have let's
say the detector that's that's measuring
the ambient noise and then that's
comparing it with the actual signal
you're trying to measure and being able
to sort of cancel out sort of echo
canceling the noise canceling headphones
and things are are trying to do exactly
that with that type of thing where
they're sort of sensing the ambient and
then getting rid of it for the signal so
I I think my guess is that that as a in
principle you should be able to have
some sort of detect heartbeats in the
distance now as a practical matter there
are much easier ways to do that if you
just want to detect the heartbeat you
don't want to measure all these
electrical signals associated with the
heart
um you know whenever we uh whenever
blood pumps through us every second or
so when a very heartbeat
um it uh oxygenated blood is is redder
in color than unoxygenated blood when
when blood is coming from the heart it's
um uh well when it's when it's some
um
when it's being pumped out it's the
lungs have put oxygen into the blood and
um when it's pumped out that will be
oxygenated blood that's being pumped out
and it's it's somewhat redder than the
blood that comes back in to the heart
after that then that oxygen gets dumped
in our tissues all over our bodies
um uh to to be part of allowing us to to
metabolize and so on in different um uh
to have energy for ourselves in
different parts of our bodies and so
that that there's slightly redder blood
that's going out than the blood that's
coming back in and so that means that
every part of us is every second is
slightly redder than it is in the off
time so to speak and so a few years ago
people had made even with with
traditional cameras like probably the
ones looking at me right now there is
you could probably measure my heart rate
by looking in precise detail at the
video frames and saying yes uh you know
that frame I'm slightly redder than I
was and that frame
um it's uh it's a small effect but it's
an effect for you to measure and that's
so from a distance you can measure heart
rates that way although for some reason
there was popularity in doing that about
five years ago but it sort of died off
um I think that it is hard you know if
you have a an infrared camera a camera
that is looking not at visible light but
uh the uh the sort of end of this at at
some electromagnetic radiation that more
corresponds to radiant heat
um the uh that's a place where you might
be able to see even more of this kind of
um well actually that that that's a
different effect you'd be seeing um you
could be seeing different um
uh different parts of uh maybe that's
probably a different I don't actually
know whether
um probably is the case that when you
pump the blood in through when the blood
is sort of Pumped out it gets slightly
hotter maybe I'm not sure actually not
sure I mean I I know that um with
infrared uh you know there's always the
question of uh for example if you stick
a thermometer in your ear that's a
barometer and what it's doing is it's
measuring infrared radiation from your
eardrum it's different from if you stick
a thermometer in your mouth for example
well the old-fashioned thermometers have
mercury in them and the Mercury expanded
uh depending on your temperature and so
you'd see the Mercury would go further
up the the tube or the thermometer if
you had a higher temperature nowadays
the thermometers you stick in your mouth
are electrical and they work by the fact
that the resistance uh to electrons
going through a metal changes with the
temperature of the metal
um so uh let's see how does it go I
think the more the higher the
temperature the more the atoms and the
metal are jiggling around and the more
difficult it is for the electron to get
make its way through the metal so the
more resistance there is to the to the
electron and you can detect that and you
can detect the change of of that
resistance as you change your
temperature when you stick the
thermometer in your mouth the
thermometer comes to equilibrium gets to
be the same temperature as that you know
pocket of heat at the back of your back
of your tongue or whatever and that's
how that works but the thermometers that
you stick in your ear they are just
looking at infrared radiation coming
from your eardrum and your eardrum is a
is a has lots of blood flow in it and
it's um it's something that will be sort
of uh more or less your core internal
temperature and it's then seeing how
much infrared light comes from that and
trying to measure that from a distance
you could say and people set these up in
well both before covert and during covid
as you know is somebody sick or not you
know look at what their temperature is
just from a distance from some infrared
camera that turns out to be pretty
difficult I mean the the uh because the
temperature of the surface of one's skin
is not necessarily that closely related
to the temperature that one is
internally so to speak
um because uh sort of uh you know out
out at the out of one's skin one's
exposed to the air which is at whatever
temperature it's at 70 degrees
Fahrenheit or something
deep inside one one might be at 98.6
degrees Fahrenheit but that's that's by
the time you're looking at the outer
surface that's it's much harder to
detect what the core temperature is you
have to make various Corrections it's
not clear that works right it's uh you
can have you know the uh uh the person
who has the you know the colder
handshake and the warmer handshake and
so on and uh they might both have the
same internal body temperature just the
difference of the the way that
capillaries and so on are delivering
heat to the extremities of of uh of the
body and so on
let's see
uh
um
oh my there's a
a comment
from uh L3 maybe
um if I'm an object moving at two thirds
of the speed of light moving towards
another object that's moving at two
thirds of the speed of light
what would the object look like to me
while on the first object
so okay what happens when you go close
to the speed of light
first point is the only way we get to
see things is by photons of Light which
go at the speed of light coming to our
eyes
okay the big thing that sort of launched
relativity in 1905
was the following surprising observation
that sort of however fast you're going
the speed of light always seems to be
the same
so that means that you might think oh if
I'm running really fast that I have a
flashlight that if I'm running at half
the speed of light and I'm shining my
flashlight out the photons coming out of
my flashlight will be going up one and a
half times the speed of light because
they got half the speed of light just by
me running and another speed of light by
them sort of being made as photons in
the flashlight so they should be going
one and a half times the speed of light
okay so the big observation which came
out of Maxwell's equations for
electromagnetism which had this property
is that the speed of light doesn't it
doesn't work that way the speed of light
is always the speed of light however
fast you're going
and so what Einstein figured out in 1905
was how could that possibly be right how
could you possibly have it be the case
that the speed of light is constant
independent of your state of motion well
the way you can have that be that way is
if actually length and time change when
you're in motion to sort of compensate
for the fact that the speed of light is
staying constant so there are two big
effects one is time dilation the other
is um uh length contraction
so time dilation says the faster you go
the slower time your time will seem to
be going relative to the time of
somebody who is staying at rest
so that means if that if you have a
clock and it ticks every second and you
think it ticks every second the person
who's at rest will see and you're going
really fast and they they pay attention
to what's happening to your clock
they'll say no no it's not ticking every
second it's ticking every five seconds
or something there's a formula the
formula is the the rate at which the
clock ticks will decrease by a factor of
one over the square root of 1 minus V
squared where V is your velocity divided
by c squared where C is the speed of
light
so it's 1 over the square root of one
minus V squared over c squared okay so
that's the formula for time dilation uh
it's also the formula for length
contraction uh lengths get for shortened
um by uh uh
um when you're traveling fast so if you
sort of see something whizzing by it
will seem to be shorter than it would be
if it was at rest
by the way in our physics project we
finally get to understand at an
intuitive level how time dilation works
I mean in other words in the way that
one describes time dilation and what I
just told you it's kind of just a
consistency condition because the speed
of light appears to be constant
therefore there must be time dilation
that's how the speed of light manages to
maintain its constancy in our physics
project we think about things this way
so you've got an object and well in our
physics project everything is Computing
all the time the progress of time is the
process of the universe Computing its
next state its next state its next state
that progression of computation is the
progress of time is the progression of
time
well motion is about an object that's
here getting reformed somewhere else
and when that object reforms itself it
has to do all kinds of computation to
take the sort of atoms of space that
represented it here and make there be
atoms of space over here that represents
the thing
so here's what happens when the thing is
just sitting still it has to compute
what it's going to what's going to
happen to it next the progress of time
as this computation so that that
computation runs at a certain rate let's
say that the object is also moving well
it's going to use some of the
computation that it can do to reform
itself at a different place and space
it's going to basically use up some
computation in doing motion so it has
less computation to uh to spend to
update its own internal state so in a
sense that's why time dilation happens
at rest all of the computation effort
can be used to just update the internal
state of the object when the thing is in
motion some of the computation of the
that gets used up in reforming the
object to different places to execute
the motion and so less computation is
available to update the object itself
and so that means that the effectively
time is running slower because there's
less
computation available to do that time
updating okay but any case the two big
effects length contraction and time
dilation two big effects and relativity
so
there's another effect as well when an
object is going away from you it gets
redshifted in other words the the
frequency of light the photon that comes
from that object essentially because the
object is going away from you the photon
the the the the the wave fronts are
being pulled apart and that causes a
light to be shifted in the red Direction
in the Spectrum red goes to low on
energy longer wavelength when an object
is going away from you that's what
happens for example distant galaxies the
the frequency of light that comes from
them the furthest away galaxies the
frequency of light is a factor of two
two and a half times uh uh smaller the
wavelength is two two and a half times
larger than it would be for a Galaxy
right next door to us and and for the
most distant objects we see in the
universe things like quasars uh there's
a factor of five difference in in
frequencies this can be a big effect
when things are going uh effectively
receding from you at a significant
fraction of the speed of light when you
get the reason in a sense if you try and
accelerate something like in a particle
accelerator try and make it faster
faster faster keep going to the speed of
light that same Formula One over one
square root of one minus V squared over
c squared is also in addition to length
contraction time dilation there's also
an increase of mass of an object and so
as you go close to the speed of light
the effective mass of an object
increases so if you're putting putting
force on the object to accelerate rate
it force force is equal to mass times
acceleration so the acceleration is if
you have a constant force the
acceleration is the force divided by the
mass and but in relativity there's a
correction factor to that because the
effective Mass goes up as the speed goes
up so as you try and get something to go
at the speed of light becomes more and
more and more difficult to get the thing
to go very close to the speed of light
and that that's why it's a sort of a it
gets infinitely difficult to make
something actually go at the speed of
light for massless particles particles
with no Mass like photons they just go
at the speed of the right all the time
but for anything with mass the effective
Mass just goes uh but gets higher and
higher and higher as you get close to
the speed of light you have to push
harder and harder and harder to get that
last you know 99.99 percent of the speed
of light okay so the question is
um
the
question was asked here was about
objects moving close to the speed of
light
objects distort in really weird ways uh
as you move close to the speed of light
for example
um actually there's a there's a chap who
was a student at a summer camp who wrote
a nice a nice uh article on kind of all
the different things you know how you
how you really think about the
appearance of objects large objects as
you go close to the speed of light
um but a lot of very weird things happen
uh I'm trying to remember some of the
effects I'm in a cube for example uh
twists if you if you have a cube going
fast because you have to think about the
the front of light coming from different
parts of the object it's actually a
fairly complicated transformation that
is lighters coming from these different
parts of the object you're deforming the
wave fronts of light
um you're you're getting often a a
strangely distorted appearance of the
object things get elongated things Get
shrunk
um it's kind of complicated and things
change color because the the when it's
going away from you fast it gets
redshifted coming towards you it gets
blue shifted and so on
so uh
let's see so I mean the the yeah there's
a lot of tricky things here I mean like
for example another
oh that there's so many sort of
paradoxes of Relativity that um happen
when you start trying to think about
large material objects so for example a
famous one is um
you're running through a barn and you
have a big Pole and the pole is much
longer than the barn but you're running
so fast that there's length contraction
on the pole so is there a moment at
which somebody can close the entry door
and the exit door from the barn and
you're in the barn just for that moment
and because you're going so fast you're
you're your pole is foreshortened and it
fits in the barn
well it's more complicated than that
because you have to start thinking about
the way that the signal to open the door
close the door how fast those signals
propagate do you know when the when
you're going to be in the barn you have
to predict that or do you have to send a
signal once you're in the barn and so on
there's a there's another one of these
there's a whole collection of these sort
of pseudo paradoxes there's another one
we have two rockets that are sort of
identically programmed to fire their
rocket thrusters and they have a string
between them and uh eventually the
Rockets if they're going sufficiently
fast will be foreshorten by length
contraction but then the question is
does the string break or not and again
it's a complicated question of what the
timing is about one rocket versus the
other and when things happen and so on
that determines that so it's fairly
complicated and it's it's some I would
say that that um I I don't I think I
have had decent but not perfect
intuition about what sort of material
objects but big things look like if
they're going close to the speed of
light
um all right I should wrap up soon here
but maybe one or two more questions I
can try
um
okay there's a question from riveting
dogs cannot understand mathematics so we
think
similarly humans must be limited in
their ability to grasp aspects of
reality is our ability to understand
upgradeable would biological evolution
with better brains or merging with AI
allow us to break through biology's
limitations and become new dogs who can
understand mathematics that's a very
interesting question
um
in a sense
every time we get new technological
devices new instruments you know when we
have an infrared camera we can see
things that were previously unseeable to
us when we have microscopes we can see
things that were previously unseeable to
us so in a sense the development of
technology is a story of us extending
our ability to understand the world the
same is true with science as we invent
new paradigms for thinking about science
we expand our ability to understand the
world in terms of this really odd
concept that I talk about we're
gradually expanding in rural space we're
gradually encompassing more different
kinds of ways to understand the universe
so I think the answer is we already have
a decent amount of experience in sort of
seeing the expansion of our sensory
capabilities through uh these these
different kinds of technological devices
now the question is do we get to provide
a narrative description a human
understandable description of what's
going on
that's an interesting challenge now
sometimes we've succeeded in doing that
you know we can describe things we see
in in through microscopes you know we
say we didn't at first we didn't know
what we were seeing through microscopes
all through telescopes we had no idea
but then we started to say that's a
Galaxy that's a you know that's a a a
Nova that happened you know this kind of
thing we have descriptive terms that
allow us to talk about things that were
initially you know distant from our
everyday experience
so
I think uh the same thing is is true of
of lots of you know as we extend our
sort of capability for uh noticing
things on the world we get to have
different kinds of descriptive terms now
for example one area is even in infrared
vision
we don't have great you know how would
we present something which is visible
light plus infrared
or with visible light our particular
sensory system senses red green and blue
but you know we could sense a hundred
different frequencies of light the
mantis shrimp I think famously senses
maybe 15 different frequency bands
um but uh you know we could sense all
these different frequency bands it might
be quite interesting because you know
based on we say I recognize that thing
it looks like copper it's copper colored
well we can pick that up by noticing
that copper has this characteristic
color that we sample from the red green
blue parts of the spectrum but if we had
hyperspectral Imaging where we're
looking at the whole range of different
uh uh different frequencies we might be
able to just look at this thing which to
us just says oh it looks like white
powder but with hyperspectral imaging we
might be able to say no no that's
calcium carbonate or something we can
immediately tell that just by virtue of
this detailed spectrum that we can sort
of hyperspectually see but one of the
questions is let's say we're going to to
present this as a technological device
and it is a near-term issue because
hyperspectral Imaging is is technically
possible the devices are still somewhat
expensive but they're coming down in
price but you know we can make a
hyperspectral Imaging device uh we can
even do that with a traditional camera
like a a standard you know webcamish
type camera phone camera or something
the um uh the way a phone camera works
is it's got these little sensors
essentially transistors that are sensing
um uh well actually more like Photo
diodes but but that that are sensing uh
kind of light falling on different parts
of this of the array that represents
sort of the retina of the camera and the
way it senses different colors is
there's a there's a mask and that mask
has sort of a red filter a green filter
a blue filter and so you know if that
particular pixel was was uh was you know
got an electrical signal that means a
the light got through the red filter and
that means it's red light and it hit
that part another part is green light it
hit that part okay so it's technically
quite easy to say well that's in
addition to red green and blue filters
let's put a whole bunch of other filters
there so that we're able to sense we're
able to detect when there's their light
of other frequencies you can do the same
kind of thing with infrared it's more
complicated because lenses and things
don't work the same way for infrared
same with UltraViolets and so on
actually existing lens systems and even
the the the sensor arrays are capable of
sensing uh somewhat into the ultraviolet
I think usually
um but it depends on those on those
filters whether they actually get to to
detect ultraviolet light and normally we
don't think that's useful because that's
not what you know when you take a
photograph with your phone and if you
take a photograph of your cat with your
phone and your phone was seeing
ultraviolet light as well as seeing
ordinary human light your cat might have
a lot of weird features you'd say that's
not my cat that's something you know
that's that's a weird ghost cat or
something and not very useful so so
that's not really done right now but
it's certainly possible to have
hyperspectral kinds of Imaging even with
fairly traditional technology so then
the question is let's say you've got a
hyperspectral image of your cat or
whatever it is how would we display that
to us
because our current sensory apparatus
only deals with RGB so we'd have to kind
of make sort of false color things we'd
have to make captions it's not really
clear how to do it it's an interesting
question I want you best do it and it's
something which would be nice to solve
because it's actually a near-term
technical possibility if we had a good
way to do it
um so that's an example of you know
we've got the technology in that case to
sense things beyond our normal sort of
uh um you know range of vision but now
the question is how do we present that
into our brains and the answer is that
will you know if we have some good user
experience some good way of some good
visualization technique or something
um we'll presumably learn oh that's what
that means just as you know when writing
was invented or something it's like that
was a bunch of squiggles well no we
learn what it means we learn kind of the
the uh we learn something which makes it
significant to us so I would expect the
same thing would happen if we had some
way of presenting kind of these
hyperspectral images and that's a way
that we're kind of extending our um uh
our sort of domain of of of capability
now you know your average dog your
average dolphin it has senses we don't
have or at least we don't have as good
versions of them you know dogs have good
senses of smell Dolphins presumably have
senses of fluid motion and things like
that
two you know if the dog could be telling
us if we could attach a dog nose to us
what would we do with the with the
results from that dog nose let's say we
could have a lovely display of kind of
you know the smell landscape from the
dog nose from the artificial dog nose
and by the way artificial noses are a
thing that have been slowly coming into
existence as a sort of chemical
detection technology gets better and so
on but so Okay so we've got our
artificial dog nose and then we're
trying to interpret what does it mean
and maybe again we'd have lovely
visualizations where you've got this
this purple piece coming in from here
and that's a sugary smell and we've got
a you know some other thing coming in
from there and it's a different color
but yeah I mean we have to then learn
sort of how do we how do we relate to
that how do we get familiar with kind of
the idea that this is that when you see
a purple piece in this place it probably
means this is going to happen
you know our we are pretty good at
learning all kinds of things about oh
this is what you see so this is going to
happen that's what a lot of experience
and training of lots of Kinds says when
you see this this is going to happen
that's what we're also trying to capture
in machine learning when we train you
know when you see this example this is
what's going to happen and you know in
lots of domains there's increasing
success in doing that
um and that in a sense could be used as
a pre-filter for you know the artificial
dog nose it's got a neural net and you
know running behind it which sort of
says um uh you know in certain cases it
says danger danger you know
killer Locust or something attack it I
don't know what that's not a good
example but but you know chemical uh
leak you know harmful chemical leak
detected or something like this
um and that that's something which is
sort of an overlay on top of the raw
data that you might otherwise be able to
detect by saying oh I know when there's
a purple and a green thing there that
corresponds to methane and you know
whatever else
um so you know that I think that's my
that's my my thinking about that and you
know what will we learn about the world
when we have more sensory modalities
probably a lot you know biology was
launched by having microscopes astronomy
by having a lot of physics by having
telescopes I think a lot of modern
physics and quantum mechanics probably
launched by having electronic amplifiers
um you know the things we learn in in
modern molecular biology from having the
ability to do sequencing and things like
this and to understand you know how a
protein is constructed those kinds of
things whenever we have these new
detection methodologies there's an awful
lot more we can understand about the
world
and once we understand it about the
world we have the potential to sort of
build our world based on that
understanding we have the potential to
do microscopic things because we've
understood stuff about the microscopic
World by using microscopes so yes I
think that that is that is the story in
a sense of the progress of technology
and of science that we gradually get to
expand our domain of both understanding
of the world sensing of the world and
making the world do things that we care
about so to speak and you know to be
able to even give an account of what it
will be like if we had that connected
dog nose or hyperspectral Imaging thing
it's very difficult it's a it's
something that I sort of um
uh kind of like to mention to science
fiction writer friends of mine as
something you know try and make
something which is sort of a description
of kind of what it's like to have very
different sensory modalities from our
own it's really hard I I was thinking
about this just recently and I'm I'm
like how do you describe this we don't
have words that describe it I mean it's
challenging enough in in things that are
Concepts and sort of the theory of
multi-computation that I've been trying
to develop and so on we don't have words
for these things you have to invent
words and you know there's only a
certain rate at which you can invent new
words if you bring in if you wheel in a
boatload of Concepts and you say I'm
going to tell you a hundred new words
good luck people are not going to
understand them there's a certain slow
rate of which you can sort of inject
things into kind of our general cultural
Consciousness
um and have people understand those
things I mean this is sort of in a sense
the story of a lot of things I've done
in my life of of trying to develop new
things uh computational language
language and so on
um a lot of things in science you know
there are one introduces things where
necessarily one is pulling in a lot of
new Concepts and to explain those
Concepts is often quite challenging and
and often sort of the anchor moment is
when you invent a word for that concept
and now you start being able to talk
about it the ruli ad for example we got
a word for it now we can start talking
about it Eames the atoms of existence
we've got a word from them just
yesterday uh there's a a new kind of
version of an atom of existence atoms of
existence have an identity but nothing
else and whenever sort of it isn't the
case that you get two copies of the same
atom of existence these Eames these
atoms of existence
um the um
uh I'm thinking uh you know an
alternative to the word eem which I
rather like would have been something
like AOE because that's atom of
existence but I don't know how you would
pronounce AOE so it's not a winner
um but uh in any case you know eems are
unique but yet we had a notion of
something which is kind of like anime
but it's more like a variable in a
programming language or a mathematical
variable it's just an X and it's sort of
an arbitrarily chosen thing but it's the
same every time it appears we need a
name for that once we have a name we'll
be able to start talking about it and
understanding it but that's kind of the
challenges how do you how do you take
and in a sense that's my my challenge my
sort of Life work is is mostly about
creating our computational language to
describe the world and really that is a
story of how do you take sort of the
complexity of the world and gradually
find these kind of Concepts that you can
name that you can piece together to talk
about the aspects of the world that we
care about
um
memes here is commenting that
smellography is an emerging field which
I've never heard of I have to go look
that up
um
and uh
uh Harry is commenting
um
that uh I think with respect to
hyperspectral Imaging no problem the
brain would just incorporate new
frequencies and we would uh see it like
a new color
I don't think so I don't think so you
say what color is that
well we've got our description we've got
our color trying but we've got our red
green blue sort of color space
something else
is really something else and it's
something where it's like I have no word
to describe that
I am seeing something where I have no
word to describe it
one of the things that's been
interesting in my life I've I've studied
quite a lot simple programs in the
computational universe
and regularly when I do that I was just
doing that last night actually I was
studying a bunch of programs never
looked at before and it's like wow these
things do a lot of complicated stuff
what do they do could I tell somebody
what they do I have no words to describe
this you can see the picture and it's
like this is doing something really
funky but I don't have a word to
describe this I don't have a way of
taking the the complexity that I'm
seeing and reducing it to just saying
there's a word that describes this and
that word is sort of a robust concept
that I can communicate to somebody else
I don't have that now if I saw enough of
those kinds of patterns I would make up
a word for example many years ago I have
this idea with the cellular automata
these simple programs of classifying
them into these four classes of behavior
and so now anybody who's in that Biz
would say if I say a class 3 cellular
automata they've immediately got an idea
what that means a class 4 cellular
Automotive they've got an idea what that
means so again that was sort of making
something like a word that classifies a
very big bucket of behavior a little bit
like you know you might save a material
oh that's a solid oh that's a liquid
things like this
um so uh
anyway it's some uh
yeah
okay one one more thing that I wasn't
willing to wrap up I'm getting reminded
here that I'm late for something else uh
there's a comment here from RBS
uh when we perceive things in 3D how
does that work is it that we're like
seeing different colors in different
eyes
no the main way we uh okay so
there's this old technology 100 years
old I think where you can put a red
filter over one eye a green filter over
the other eye and uh that's and then you
can look at an image and that image will
seem like it has depth the way that we
see depth we perceive depth in our eyes
is that we've got two eyes and we're
seeing things from slightly different
angles something that is a few feet away
the there is a certain difference of
angles of what we're seeing we're seeing
one side of the thing when we have from
our left eye and one side of the pin
from our right eye when the thing is
close to us there's a much bigger
disparity there's a much bigger
difference between what we see out of
our left eye and what we see at our
right eye when the thing is a long way
away there's only a tiny difference of
angle between seeing for my left eye and
seeing our right eye and so the images
are much closer together and our brain
and our visual cortex at the back of our
heads has a pretty good way of of
comparing the images from left and right
eyes there are no fibers that kind of
get mixed up from the left eye and the
right eye and there's the sort of
comparison that's happening in our
brains where we say how much difference
is there between that part of the image
between the left eye and the right eye
and so that that's some
that's how we sense depth that's how we
tell how far away something is and
that's a good example actually of a of a
level of perception that is beyond sort
of color and things like that that's a
pretty subtle level of perception that
we are getting in those nerve fibers in
our brains that um comes from sort of
this fact that we have two eyes and
we're looking at things from two
different angles I mean if we were an
insect or something that has this this
compound eye with you know hundreds of
different little eye pieces you know we
have to integrate that in a different
way we have a very different experience
of vision
um but but so the way that mostly the
way we see depth is by uh is by this
comparison between our two eyes now it's
not the only way we see depth because
even in a photograph you can say you
know in oh there's perspective there's a
there's this thing which looks like a
crater or looks like a hill
um and you know it has Shadows on it and
we're seeing depth that way we also get
cues about depth and things like Shadows
and shapes in general and uh the uh when
they're they're now machine learning
systems that will guess the 3D structure
of an image just by from its 2D
structure in fact that's used sometimes
to make a movie that was originally a a
2d movie and sort of make it 3D without
having had two cameras photographing the
whole movie is by using this kind of
fact that oh one kind of knows that this
thing is that shape and so so and and
for example when there are multiple
frames in a movie you can kind of see
between the different frames in the
movie you're kind of going around the
same object and so you get a sense of it
3D shape I have to say that 3D movies
have not been as popular as people have
thought multiple times in history they
would be and so that technology I don't
think has gone as far as it might have
done but yeah the the way that we sense
uh sort of um distance
um is uh uh is by is by this comparison
of what we see out of our left eye and
our right eye that's the primary way but
also just by knowing what things look
like and sometimes we get confused there
are there are
um you know they're a kind of um uh
optical illusions and things like the
the standard illusion where you say is
it a crater or is it a hill based on
this sort of circle and then you've got
this kind of uh uh this piece that that
makes a shadow and and sometimes it even
will will pop between one and the other
as as your brain kind of says I think
it's that I think it's that and so on so
that that's that's how that works and I
think
um in uh By the way when it comes to
sensing depth there's a big cheat that's
used by your average cell phone these
days
um and and it's also used by 3D scanners
which is this approach it's called
structured light and so what happens is
your phone for example projects a grid
of infrared light
um onto your face for example and by
seeing where that grid if if your face
was flat and that grid was projected in
in the right way it would just be a
straight grid on your face but if your
face isn't flat that grid will be
distorted that grid as seen by the
camera will be distorted by the fact
that some parts of that grid were
falling on something which was further
away than others and so a lot of you
know when uh when you're doing 3D scans
with a phone for example when it's doing
face recognition for example
um it's typically using you know the
shape of your head is detected by
looking at the Distortion to the
structured light to this array this grid
of infrared light that's projected it on
your face
um and that's that's sort of the the big
cheat that we humans don't get to use we
don't have a you know an infrared um
thing that's uh that's sort of detecting
a 3D structure another example this is
lidar
um in uh sort of the fanciest
self-driving cars uh have these have
these things usually these days there's
still this sort of uh donut shaped thing
on top of the car which is has a big
spinning thing inside it that is using
infrared light again to um uh uh to
detect
uh well that that's more sort of
detecting how long it takes for a signal
to come back reflected from something
and able to form a 3D map of the
environment that way and that's what one
does for for sort of the the fanciest 3D
uh fanciest autonomous Car Technology
that other cars like like Teslas use
just cameras
um and they're they're having to use the
technology that's much more like the way
humans do it
um of both um uh
um and I don't think they're using no I
don't I don't think they use structured
light I think they're just using pure
camera images and they're using
differences of of images from two
different cameras and they're using sort
of the the progression of the image over
time and and things like that to be able
to sense 3D structure they have a nice
typically have a nice kind of display
that shows you the reconstructed 3D
image in real time
um and you know you can see that some of
it is quite accurate and some of it just
Goofs completely and some of it is like
yes it recognizes there's a there's a
van there there's a car there there's a
person there there's a bicycle there and
I I do kind of wonder I haven't had a
chance to try this in an exotic location
where there are all kinds of you know
safari animals running around I I don't
know what it thinks some of those things
are
um I would be curious to know and that's
a sort of situation a little bit like
the situation with humans where we are
presented with something which is just
very different from our common
experience and it's like what is that
thing do we have a description of it in
looking at sort of this this
computational universe of possible
programs that's a really common thing to
see something you know what is that
thing how would we describe it
all right I should wrap up here for
today uh thanks for lots of interesting
questions and I see there are many saved
up but I'll also try and address new
ones
um I think I may miss next week but um I
should be back um uh back with you all
soon
um on another live stream and um I do
remind people if you are curious about
other topics I have now done
what is it maybe a hundred of these that
right sounds about right
um and uh they are pretty nicely
archived together with word clouds of
the topics and text to questions and so
on and so um uh probably searchable and
you can find what goofy things I've said
about um all kinds of different topics
anyway thanks for joining me this time
and see you another time and bye for now